the Joe Rogan experience I'm thinking
about moving to New York in December why
to work how you gonna come up with a new
hour why do you want to move to New York
and get out of school - no just me
New York for like two weeks and just
[ __ ] do two weeks though yeah yeah
for two weeks just come for two weeks
and do spots like crazy
yeah when right you do spots in LA and
still see your family bro Jesus I like I
like shaking it up Joe shake it up
I've had that fantasy before yeah I've
had the exact same fantasy doing them
the fantasy came before I already
drugged me cuz I was like oh he's so
great to be hard for two weeks and just
go do spots with him big Jay hugged but
it'll be cool it would be cool yeah but
you're not friends anymore you can't do
that how much I'm you know how much I
love already that I have been damage
control trying to take care of him in
this I would you appreciate that I
really care about it on a podcast
no talk about it at all wait we'll talk
about on the podcast there during the
weekend I was like maybe everyone I was
worried about already and I was like I
don't maybe I shouldn't bring this up I
don't think it's a good thing and I
think Ari
maybe regrets it but yeah definitely
doesn't look at his face he does not
regret it no that's the real problem
here I think is that I don't regret I
think that is a problem
yeah I won't do it again but I don't
regret why do you not regret for real
why don't you regret it was all I've
nothing bad happened and it was awesome
and he's and his wife is mad at me again
but that's definitely not gonna be the
last time or it's not the first time I
thought is unfortunate but worth it I
think great time I love I would love to
see the video of Bert like it kind of
him realizing it I have it really when
you realize it's like kicking in yeah I
remember I can't tell you I can't tell
you
hey guys saw it today because I'm
debating whether to release that podcast
but I saw it nice when it's I see it in
my eyes I go back to that [ __ ] moment
where I'm like when you realize the
United control it's like it's like
getting Stromberg has strapped into a
one of the [ __ ] hot rods mmm the
[ __ ] - the jet fueled ones and they
strapped
mian super-tight and then they strap my
hands so I couldn't touch anything and I
remember I couldn't get out and I had a
panic attack I said I'm gonna be here
for a while like I was like cuz they
were like and I was like I need to get
out right now I need to get out right
now
and I had to get out it was one of
during tribal channel were you leave
that to me I said I can't get out of
this [ __ ] panic I go I can't fix this
and then it overwhelmed me that's how I
feel I take mushrooms overwhelm me and I
thought I'm what if I don't like this
what if I don't enjoy this how do I stop
this I can't stop it
no that's a [ __ ] that's a panic
attack right there but luckily it was it
was a very it's Molly's a really
interesting drug it'll fight for you
it'll be an advocate Molly was like
don't worry your cousin's here rub his
back because you did that to him do you
think we could allow him to do Molly in
October I would say okay do you want to
do it no I'm not doing any Molly ever
again Oh ever and OD I'm never good
about November first
dude you should have seen I was here's
what sucked about it as soon as he gave
it to me I felt it kick in I went I
don't want to do this podcast I wanna go
for a walk yeah I want to do Mona go
dance I want to listen to music I want
my children and wife not to be here I
want to not have to explain the
situation to my wife I want to not have
to be on a plane so like I don't know
maybe I would do Molly in the future if
it was like an awesome concert or
something in Vegas or yeah cool sounds
awesome
right like Britney Spears or some dude I
would do Molly and go to Britney Spears
sure you remember all the lyrics all the
songs dude or you better work [ __ ]
yeah I do some Taylor Swift the best was
that so I started dancing a little bit
cuz I know I was taken so it was like
embracing kicking it and you sugars out
of blue
you were Molly right now or are you and
then we just kiss like I don't know what
that was do you do it
I do what what it's the right time I
wants to see Mighty Mighty Bosstones in
the Orient Webster Hall I did that night
you know you're an adult right yeah what
are you doing Molly for what do you mean
you know what it feels great
yeah but he's gotten hit first of all
his balls don't work so he can't make
babies he had him snipped so he doesn't
have real responsibilities none I think
if you have more
you don't do it all time just in the
right like musically how often is that
now it again three times a year four
times a year oh okay that's not bad yeah
festivals occasional bird is maybe twice
a year
Iza do Co not that in the Koch hoax
awesome really this is why it's a
rabbits all of the issuer was real
emotion by that in the world yeah was
last time you did it
it's been a long time I didn't an
accident one night accident yeah my
buddies had that bullet where you load
it and then flip it and they have a
little bump for you and you can hit it
and they couldn't figure out how to work
it and I'm watching them I was getting
ready go to this spot is long I was in
New York I was watching my go guys
you're doing it wrong give me the
[ __ ] thing I go you take it right
then you load it then we hit it you got
to hit it know what I used to cook a lot
in New York and then you want onstage
and destroyed Joey says that coke [ __ ]
his comedy up I already said it made him
good you might go a little deeper takes
away your heart takes away the heart
imagine him though like if you go like
let's really do some coke it's not a
line he's probably just the whole bag
got a machine gun crazy bomb
[Applause]